YouTube va mal :(
*Musique*
"Cette vidéo n’était pas du tout prévue à la base, mais vu ce qu'il se passe en ce moment,
j'me suis dit que c’était pas une si mauvaise idée de vous tenir au courant."
"Vous avez raison, YouTube veut bien nous enc**er, et genre mais bien sec."
"Et en effet Youtube a décidé de... euh de nous enc****
(Il dit lentement): de nous enc****
Récemment Youtube a changé son algorithme et quelques bugs ont fait leur apparition :
- YouTube désabonne automatiquement les gens de certaines chaînes YouTube
- Le compteur de vues fait de l'immense merde
Et enfin le pire de tous : les gens ne reçoivent plus dans leurs fils d'abonnements
les vidéos des gens auxquels ils se sont abonnés.
Ça a entraîné une baisse des vues,
une baisse du nombre d'abonnés
et une baisse de motivation de la part de tous les créateurs de contenu.
Mais le VRAI sujet de cette vidéo c'est l'algorithme et tout ce que ça implique.
L'algorithme de YouTube c'est quoi ?
C'est un système qui fonctionne de manière indépendante
et totalement automatique et qui met en avant des vidéos en se basant sur certains critères :
- Le "watchtime", à savoir quel pourcentage de la vidéo le mec qui a cliqué dessus a regardé
- Le nombre de pouces bleus et le nombre de commentaires
Ca a fonctionné comme ça pendant des années mais YouTube n'a jamais donné sur quels critères se basait son algorithme
sinon ça n'aurait plus de sens puisque tout le monde aurait abusé.
Mais attendez ! Est-ce qu'y a pas déjà plein de gens qui ont totalement abusé quand même ?
*Si tu veux qu'on continue les vidéos prank, oublie pas de mettre ton petit pouce bleu au début de la vidéo fréro*
*Bonjour, le ministère de la culture vous informe que si cette vidéo vous enjaille*
*vous pouvez cliquer sur le pouce bleu et vous abonner à la chaîne d'Amixem*
*Si vous voulez que je tente en vidéo, eh bah on va dire 10 000 likes sur cette vidéo*
*Éteins la lumière, mets le son à fond, et mets un gros like sur ma vidéo*
*Si tu kiffes alors mets un pouce bleu ma couille*
*Juste avant que la vidéo commence je t'invite à mettre un like*
*Lâche un pouce bleu*
*Clique sur j'aime*
*Vous cliquez le petit pouce bleu*
Bref, l'algorithme de YouTube a changé et maintenant les vidéos qui sont mises en avant
dans les suggestions, sur la page d'accueil, ou dans l'onglet "Tendances", ne sont plus du tout les même qu'avant.
Du coup les gens qui falsifiaient leurs stats et qui abusaient de l'algorithme,
qui avaient donc une mise en avant monstrueuse,
EH BEN ! AS-TU VU TON NOMBRE DE VUES BAISSER ?
PUTAIN !
J'comprends qu'on puisse en vouloir à YouTube pour les bugs que j'ai cité au début de la vidéo,
c'est n'importe quoi et ça pénalise énormément les petits et moyens YouTubers,
et c'est ceux qu'il faut le moins pénaliser aujourd'hui.
Qu'un gros YouTuber fasse plus que un tiers des vues qu'il faisait avant
c'est pas grave il gagnera quand même de l'argent, il pourra quand même vivre,
il continuera quand même ses vidéos et ça fera toujours pas mal de vues.
Mais qu'un petit YouTuber qui est déjà un peu ric-rac, et même niveau motivation, il attend que sa chaîne prenne de l'ampleur et avance,
et on lui met des bâtons dans les roues comme ça, ÇA c'est dégueulasse !
Ma question est la suivante :
"Peut-on vraiment en vouloir à YouTube d'avoir modifié son algorithme ?"
NON !
EH NON les gars !
Chez YouTube ils sont pas dupes, ils ont vu que tout le monde arrivait à comprendre l'algorithme et à le manipuler.
Comme ce très cher IbraTV, et ses... "poces bleus", qui sont devenus sa marque de fabrique.
*Moi je suis, l'empereur de poces bleus*
*Poce bleu*
*Mettez 200 000 poces bleus*
*J'ai 300 000 poces bleus*
*Faudra mettre 100 000 poces bleus*
*POCES BLEUS*
C'est normal de donner un objectif de pouces bleus à CHACUNE de ses PUTAINS de vidéos ?
C'est un truc que tu fais quand tu sors un gros projet ou quand tu fais très peu de vidéos.
Antoine Daniel pourrait le faire
*rires*
Quand c'est un évènement, quand c'est un truc qui change, qui est, voilà...
sur lequel t'as bossé à mort, LÀ ok !
Mais demander des putains de pouces bleus en début de vidéo,
c'est comme juger une pomme avant de l'avoir mangée.
PewDiePie c'est pour toi :
Il faut au moins que t'aies croqué la pomme,
donc devant une vidéo il faut au moins que t'aies regardé un bout de la vidéo.
C'est bien de vouloir soutenir les créateurs que l'on kiffe, mais le système de pouces bleus
il est là pour dire si t'aimes bien ou pas une vidéo.
Si juste t'écoutes bêtement ce que le YouTuber te dit et que tu te fais pas ton propre avis sur la vidéo,
ça craint, ça pue du cul.
Du coup on sait pas trop sur quoi le nouvel algorithme se base, mais tout le monde a remarqué
que PLUS une vidéo fait un nombre record de pouces bleus en peu de temps,
PLUS elle va être en avant et elle va se retrouver dans les Tendances.
Mais nan mais j'arrête pas de voir des gens chialer sur les réseaux sociaux :
"YouTube meurt" "C'est la fin de YouTube" blablabla...
Et y'en a plein qui disent ça pour les bonnes raisons, qui sont les bonnes,
mais d'autres qui parlent QUE d'algorithme et qui flippent parce qu'ils voient leur nombre de vues baisser.
Mais franchement, aujourd'hui, on se concentre plus sur :
"Est-ce que ma vidéo a un bon titre ? Une bonne miniature ?"
Et SURTOUT : "Est-ce qu'elle a beaucoup de pouces bleus ? Est-ce que les gens vont mettre beaucoup de commentaires ?"
"Faut que je trouve un moyen qu'ils le fassent, comme ça elle est mise en avant et je fais des vues".
Ça fait combien d'années qu'un mec ne s'est pas posé la question : "Est-ce que ma vidéo elle est bien ?" ?
C'est vrai ou pas ?
Ça fait combien d'années qu'un mec s'est pas dit ça ?
C'est la base quand même ! C'est faire des vidéos qui sont bien !
Trouver le meilleur moyen de faire des vidéos cool, qui plaisent,
et qui NOUS plaisent, à nous les créateurs.
Aujourd'hui, plein de gens râlent parce-qu'ils voient des trucs de merde mis en avant,
des vidéos pas drôles, pas cool, nulles.
Mais les amis, ceux qui mettent leurs bons pouces bleus en début de vidéo avant même d'avoir regardé, ils contribuent à ça.
Ceux qui écoutent leur idole qui leur dit : "Aime la vidéo!"
Vous contribuez à cette merde !
Putain j'me laisse aller comme David Lafarge et Siphano, ça va pas du tout.
*Eh ouais, la vérité elle est là gros.*
MERCI DE M'AVOIR MONTRÉ L'EXEMPLE À NE PAS SUIVRE LES GARS ! MERCI !!
Donc les YouTubers plus petits qui ont pas des millions d'abonnés mais qui font quand même pas mal de vues,
parce-que faut pas oublier que 50 000, 100 000 vues c'est ÉNORME putain !
On l'oublie parce-qu'on pense qu'aux millions de vues. Même moi, des fois, une vidéo elle fait 1 million de vues,
j'fais : "Oh, elle a bidé !"
**Bruit de gifle**
Mais ferme-la gamin !
Faut arrêter de chialer aussi, putain !
Bref j'ai pas de morale ou de leçon à donner à la fin de cette vidé...
Ah ! IbraTV a sorti une nouvelle vidéo, attendez...
*Alors le but c'est de faire 1 million d'abonnés, en plus, en 24h*
*Si... euh... vous faites ça, je vais supprimer ma chaîne, je vais faire une dernière vidéo dans laquelle...
**Applaudit et fait tomber son casque**
C'est la première fois de ma vie que je vois un YouTuber plus se foutre de votre gueule que des hommes politiques, mon gars.
Et ce qui est drôle, c'est que ce gars est le gars le MOINS pénalisé par les politiques YouTube !
Au contraire, c'est celui qui a le plus bénéficié du changement d'algorithme,
et c'est celui qui veut prendre les mesures les plus drastiques pour montrer à YouTube qu'il est pas content ?!!
Bon dites-moi que personne n'y a cru et nourrit ces conneries.
*Il crie dans son micro*
Bref, j'te blâme pas IbraTV... T'as tes raisons... que la raison ignore.
Franchement, à un moment, il faut arrêter les conneries.
Venez, on fait tous juste des vidéos, on essaie de faire des bonnes vidéos pour les gens qui sont sur la plateforme, ok ?
On arrête de gueuler.
Ils ont vu qu'on a gueulé, juste PewDiePie, PewDiePie, number one au monde,
fait tout un coup de gueule autour de ça... Ils ont vu !
Bref je comprends que les YouTubers soient pas contents, mais il faut pas en venir à faire n'importe quoi,
et à ramper à terre pour être mis en avant par l'algorithme de YouTube.
En fait, actuellement, l'algorithme a changé et tout le monde cherche comment faire et sur quoi il se base pour qu'il nous mette en avant.
Bah les gars, la réponse elle est toute bête :
Faites des bonnes vidéos !
Au revoir et Ta mère la chienne